تقول بريطانيا إنها استأجرت بارجة
لإيواء بعض طالبي اللجوء،
وسوف ترسو السفينة في جنوب إنجلترا
وتأوي حوالي 500 من طالبي اللجوء بينما
تتم معالجة طلباتهم،
وتصف الحكومة ذلك بأنه إجراء لتوفير التكلفة
حيث تواجه المملكة المتحدة تدفقًا هائلاً
للمهاجرين  عبور القناة في
قوارب صغيرة الآن تدين مجموعات حقوق الإنسان
القرار قائلة إنه
قاسٍ، ويقول رئيس وزرائنا أوشي سوناك إن
حكومته لم يكن لديها الكثير من
الخيارات،
ولا يمكننا الحصول على وضع
ننفق فيه بشكل جماعي ستة ملايين جنيه إسترليني
يوميًا  فنادق لمتحدثي اللجوء غير الشرعيين،
نحن نقدم
مواقع بديلة مثل البارجة
التي أعلنا عنها اليوم والتي
ستوفر لنا المال وتقلل بالفعل الضغط
على الفنادق، وكل ذلك جزء من خطتنا لإيقاف
القارب
الآن سوف تؤوي العصيدة التي تسمى بيبي ستوكهولم
طالبي اللجوء لمدة
18 شهرًا على الأقل، تقول الحكومة البريطانية إنها
تستكشف إمكانية استخدام المراكب الإضافية كما سمعتم للتو
من رئيس الوزراء